bei diesen aprilscherz wurde sein
bürostuhl einfach durch eine toilette
ausgetauscht wir können aber ganz nah
sein dann kannst du beim arbeiten kacken
ja ich weiß es der erste april bereits
32 tage her ist allerdings habe ich mir
dann auch gedacht dass wir uns heute war
einfach zu sammeln die witzigsten april
ich glaube mein schreibtisch ist rott
wir schauen uns heute gemeinsam einige
der lustigsten aprilscherze an
und das hier ist direkt das erste meine
damen und herren wir sehen einen monat
und anstatt dass dort vanillecreme drin
ist ist dort mirakel wird drinnen den
hätte ich nicht gern gegessen hat jemand
an die wand wo die türklinke gegen
knallt ein hohen angebracht also sondern
ding hier wenn die tür dagegen geht dann
wird sich dann voll auf meinem
bildschirm geraubt es kommt auf jeden
fall ein lautes wenn man die tür öffnet
ach du heilige scheiße
die hat einer in das büro einfach
hunderte dächer verteilt mit wasser drin
also man kann ja auch nicht einfach alle
umkippen wenn man muss wirklich jeden
einzelnen weg ich würde dich töten für
diesen aprilscherz hat die personen
weißen kleber und glas gebraucht und hat
dann ein 8
ach so der das natürlich auch böse
allerdings nur zu einem aprilscherz der
nicht irgendwie von einer privatperson
unterliegen dem typen an seinen freund
freundin oder so gemacht wurde sondern
der nächste aprilscherz kam von
mcdonald's die haben nämlich einen
drücke ein drückeberger gemacht es gebe
locker leute die das kaufen würden das
ist einfach ein smoothie mitbürger
geschmack ist so traurig mcdonald's dann
allerdings auch noch einen zweiten
abriss rausgehauen
die waren ganz lustig unterwegs und
haben aus einem milchshake saucen
rausgehauen denn es gibt ja wirklich
leute die dann ihre pommes irgendwie in
das eishockey oder so deswegen haben
jetzt hier erdbeer milchshake vanille
schokolade und keine ahnung was das sein
soll da bin ich aber ganz ehrlich das
wäre sogar nice jetzt meine pommes auch
meistens mit als das hier ist was ganz
ganz gemeines und zwar sieben auf der
linken seite cake pops heißt die glaube
ich also
wieso kuchen mit schokolade darüber an
so einem spiel mit streuseln aber es ist
in wirklichkeit das hier lachen
er hat einfach salatköpfe
die sache ist dass es wahrscheinlich
sogar recht schmecken würde und es wäre
gut für kinder dass sie hat gesund essen
hat jemand auf die heckklappe des autos
eines freundes geschrieben hongkong wave
and jamie dass genau dies ist hier happy
april fool's day also jemand der das
lied soll einfach guten winken und
schreibt jason l bist du der nächste
aprilscherz ist von einem unternehmen
namens highway und zwar haben sie
geschrieben wurde lounge im aussennetz
make-up roger und es ist einfach nichts
es ist einfach luft in einem glas ist am
nächsten aprilscherz frage ich mich hey
wer würde darauf hereinfallen es ist ein
gefrorenes müsli eingefrorene froot
loops an mich denken aber wer würde
darauf reinfallen
weil wenn ich auf der arbeit rumlaufe
und da ist halt ne müsli schale dann
würde ich da nicht einfach denke hey wie
es sich jetzt aufwachen allerdings
direkt weiter mit einem aprilscherz der
ebenfalls auf der arbeit stattgefunden
hat uns war dieser hier
er hat einfach unter dieses laser ting
von der maus ein
tesa streifen geklebt das heißt die
reihe gelegt die person wird
wahrscheinlich ein arbeitsplatz gehen
wir denken hey ich s college wir sind
roma das geht nicht
der mann schreibt es tut mir echt leid
pro video echt so 40 mal drauf dass
jetzt der nächste aprilscherz und zwar
wurden einfach alle produkte im
kühlschrank mit augen versehen könnte
auch luca sei mit seiner ukulele damals
der nächste scherz ist immer wieder von
einem unternehmen und zwar von google
die haben google tulpe rausgebracht ich
habe euch das video mal und in der
beschreibung verlinkt da könnt ihr euch
das komplette video mal anschauen wenn
ihr das machen wollte ich habe euch eben
noch ein paar andere sachen auch und in
der beschreibung verlinkt also check
gern mal die video beschreibung ab aber
es geht dabei doch einfach 2,7 millionen
aufrufe nach drei tagen könnt ihr meine
videos auch so häufig anklicken mehr
voll nett dankeschön es geht bei diesem
google tool aber auf jeden fall darum
dass man mit seinen blumen sprechen kann
hey ich hätte gern ein bisschen mehr
wasser und blumen
beispielsweise auch sowas sagen wie
apropos lukasz ob da werde ich demnächst
mal die neuen produkte vorstellen die am
in den luca shop kommen werden das ist
auf jeden fall der nächste aprilscherz
und zwar haben dort seine
arbeitskollegen einfach alle seine
geräte also seine schere seinem aus und
dass die hier seinen tucker oder was
auch sein sollen die haben einfach alles
in wackelpudding verwendet
beziehungsweise wackelpudding drumrum
gemacht hat da was zu essen das jetzt
halt so ein standard aprilscherz
beziehungsweise standard aprilscherz
aber ich glaube den gibt es in nahezu
jedem unternehmen und zwar die einfach
alles wirklich alles eingewickelt in
frischhaltefolie wenn ich an meinen
arbeitsplatz gehen wird ich würde direkt
wieder nach hause abchecken machen wir
allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten aprilscherz von einem
unternehmen und zwar von einer zeitung
und zwar dem merkur ist
die haben nämlich gesagt dass die
entscheidung gefallen ist und die
komplette frankfurter innenstadt
autofrei wird soll ich mal ganz gut
gegen dimitri geworfen
dadurch war das hier ist der nächste
aprilscherz er am arbeitsplatz
vonstatten gegangen ist ich fand das mit
der frischhaltefolie ja schon schlimm
und hätte da wahrscheinlich gesagt ich
fahre nach hause aber hier hätte ich
wahrscheinlich ja meinen kompletten
schreibt es einfach angezündet hast das
auch einfach für eine heidenarbeit sein
muss
der nächste aprilscherz ist etwas wo ich
hätte wirklich drauf reinfallen können
und wo ich mir auch wirklich in die
hosen gemacht hätte und zwar dass hier
er hat einfach fette kakerlaken
ausgeschnitten und dienst innere von
beispielsweise hier sondern ikea lampe
gesetzt dass man es abends halt erst
sinn wenn man wirklich das licht anmacht
und dann ist auf einmal so als hättest
in der lampe
wer komplett dreimal im quadrat
gesprungen der nächste aprilscherz es
einfach so ekelhaft gemein alter es ist
ein berliner allerdings anstatt süßer
marmelade ist dort ketsch
[Gelächter]
so im dreieck gekotzt hat die freundin
wohl ihrem partner 20 chicken mcnuggets
mitgebracht hat dort allerdings gemüse
fakt ist so gemein aber bleibt auf jeden
fall bis zum ende dran freude denn es
gibt noch ein aprilscherz der so ähnlich
ist er ist auch so krass machen
allerdings erstmal weiter mit diesen
aprilscherz und zwar sehen wir schon das
ist nur eine toilette in diesem raum
frei ist wahrscheinlich auch auf der
arbeit irgendwo gewesen und auf die
toilette sind ja auch schon recht
eingeblendet das ist einfach nur ein
fake mensch ist einfach schuhe mit ikea
hat natürlich auch etwas gepostet wieder
am ersten april das machen wir auch
jedes jahr und zwar um sie diesmal
gesagt dass sie einen golddorf bringen
also ein hotdog mit blattgold auflage
der winter wahrscheinlich anstatt ein
euro einfach zwei euro kosten der
nächste aprilscherz ist auch wieder so
ekelhaft und ist wieder so ein bisschen
so wie dieser berliner aprilscherz was
ist das hier das ist eine coca cola dose
mit einem strohhalm drin aber er trinkt
nicht aus der coca cola sondern aus der
tüte ketsch war so ekelhaft machen die
nächste bricht jetzt kenne ich schon aus
einigen frank videos auf youtube und
zwar ist es dieser hier also auf die
männer toilette wird einen rock daran
geklebt so dass die frauen denken das
ist die frauentoilette es ist dann
allerdings die männertoilette hallo
leute haben wir alle gelacht zunächst
aprilscherz ist tatsächlich ein
aprilscherz von einem youtuber gewesen
und zwar von dem herrn christian
solmecke das ist ein rechtsanwalt aus
köln und zwar der gesagt sensation
artikel 13 gekippt er hat in diesem
video gesagt dass artikel 13 doch noch
gekippt wurde hat am ende allerdings
gesagt hey es war ein aprilscherz als
ich das erst gesehen habe habe ich mich
so gefreut und danach habe ich einfach
nur noch geheult playstation hat als
aprilscherz rausgehauen dass sie einen
playstation schlüsselanhänger
produzieren so dass man seine
playstation immer an seinem schlüssel
mit dabei haben kann dieser aprilscherz
ist einfach so easy zu machen man
braucht einfach nur eine rolle klopapier
und ein bisschen wasser und dann sieht
es aus in den kap wurst und man kann ihn
beispielsweise einfach auf dem bürostuhl
legen oder neben die maus von einem
typen ich würde mich dumm und dämlich
ekel nie hat jemand einer person das
apple ipad geschenkt hat allerdings in
die verpackung nicht das eigentliche
gerät gepackt sondern
ein ipad also kosmetik dem was man für
die augen benutzt kann der nächste
aprilscherz ist wieder so ekelhaft und
ich wäre hundertprozentig darauf
reingefallen und zwar sind es donnert
die allerdings nicht mit puderzucker
voll sind sondern mit babypuder
menschenrechte sind sämtlich abstoßen
als nächstes hat hier jemand einfach das
fahrrad seines kollegen an eine statue
geheim
da muss es halt auch erst mal runter
kriegen also das ist ja ähnlich so vom
prinzip her wie diese becher die alle in
den büros standen aber das hier auch
noch alles abzuziehen alter das ist ja
auch so ne scheiße arbeit bei diesen
aprilscherz wurde aus der 5 gaben
kaugummi verpackung das kaugummi raus
genommen ersetzt durch play du also
durchkneten
das heißt du packst das kaugummi aus und
kauft richtig geil auf kneten dieser
aprilscherz ist einfach so teuflisch es
sind einfach diese schoko ostereier
aber es sind weintrauben drin die sache
ist du musst halt doch erstmal die
verpackung von einem schokopudding so
perfekt abkriegen dass es dann wieder
perfekt um eine weintraube rumkommt
kommen wir nun allerdings zu dem
aprilscherz wo ich euch vorhin schon
gesagt habe hey ihr müsst auf jeden fall
bis zum ende dran bleiben und zwar sagen
einfach mal eine freundin bringt hier
ihren partner essen mit nach hause ihr
freund hat sich allerdings schon immer
ein neues handy gewünscht und dann ist
in dieser verpackung ein iphone oder
denkt nicht geil meine freundin hat mir
ein handy mit gebracht dann machte
allerdings die verpackung vom iphone auf
und daran ist dann das essen das ist ein
doppelter aprilscherz man das ist so nah
ist kommen wir nun allerdings meine
damen und herren zum letzten
aprilscherzen ich euch heute vorbereitet
haben und zwar von niemand geringerem
getätigt worden
luca eurem lieblings youtuber ich lösche
mein youtube april april du wenn euch
das video gefallen hat ein tick unter
dem video auf den daumen hoch button und
auf abonnieren das würde mich sehr
freuen und schreibt ihr unten in die
kommentare über welchen aprilscherz ihr
euch am meisten aufgeregt hätte wenn ihr
euch zugefügt worden wäre
[Musik]